Um,
we're back live, folks. I got nothing
left today. Honestly, I got nothing
left. Um,
I think what I'm going to try to do,
I'm just going to get benchmark numbers
for some environments and call it a day.
I think that's all we need to do for
right now.
Let me go start on that.
Um,
I just I'm I'm exhausted. I really just
need to figure out how long it takes to
solve some M's and then we'll call it a
day.
One
2 3
taking Sunday off if I can. I guess
I mean I got nothing
end solve time.
Maybe I should just do um
I mean, is this the right thing to be
really looking at?
This is a good visual.
Solve time.
fascinating about RL. Um,
it can solve really unintuitive problems
that you can't solve with basically any
other method and you can do it virtually
instantly on pretty low-end hardware.
It's a much much more efficient uh
computationally efficient learning
method. The really big models
also interactive learning. Interactivity
seems pretty fundamental to
intelligence.
Many things really.
that this isn't the right thing to show
is the problem.
Best way to get into this topic.
My guides,
they link you to everything you need.
They're on the articles tab right
here. Articles tab.
Um well our company we build high
performance custom simulations
for um companies that are using
reinforcement learning. So we make
people's stuff run like a thousand times
faster, much more stable. We integrate
all of our tools. We push the cutting
edge of research and we bundle it up
nicely. A lot of things
I actually don't know. There are few
that I like. I'm trying to think who's
been doing good stuff lately, though.
There really hasn't been that much
lately from um
the people that I had like that I really
like their work
haven't really been putting out that
much stuff in the last few years.
I mean some people that you probably
don't know of uh if you're not already
an RL.
Michael in um Forers Lab at Oxford is
very good. Costa's old stuff in RL is
very good. Chris Bamford's stuff. Um,
back when he was working on Gridley was
very good.
Uh, oh, who's the guy that did Net Hack?
Net Hack Learning Environment was very
good.
A few different people.
I would say Carathy, but he's kind of
gone off the deep end lately.
Let me go look at the um the script I
wrote. Maybe I can flip it.
Yan, Lun, and Ilia.
Yen's got a couple reasonable things.
And Ila, yeah, definitely is one of my
um
my favorites, but I haven't like I don't
know what he's working on lately, so
what what can I say, right?
I mean, yes, in the past,
obviously, but I don't know what he's
been doing lately. Nobody really does.
What is this?
I'm trying to figure out
I got to change one thing with the
trailer. Don't I?
You know what?
I think I know what I should do. I need
to swap the trailer, don't I?
But I don't want to give myself a ton of
additional editing work. Okay, let me
think.
Try this.
Maybe I can get pong like super fast.
Oh, interesting.
The pong can even go faster.
Pong is tiny.
No, it's 438 ms long train.
Pretty funny though.
It actually works better without. That's
funny.
Yo, Kvert, look at this. 435MS
80 by 100. Oh, nice. I forget what mine
is. I think this is is it like 45 by 65
or something? It's something around
there.
Uh, hang on. I'm trying to figure out
what I do here.
Why did it kill my chat window? That's
weird.
All right. Here we'll just do that.
We'll do it this way.
That's working right.
I hope
Um,
video editor.
Well, I have a shortcut on Linux, right?
Yeah. Let me go re-record the uh the
ocean trailer.
Somebody typed something in the chat so
I know if it's broken or not.
I don't think it's broken, but I don't
know. Here, I'll go open up the Twitch.
Oh, it's not. It's good.
Thanks Kvert.
I think it needs the full set, doesn't
it?
In which case I don't even need to
re-record it, do I?
Oh god, where did I save this [ __ ] to?
Do you caffeinate?
Not at this hour, but yeah, I got
coffee.
This is super annoying. Like I literally
just don't remember.
Hang on, let me go look for it.
I'm trying to remember where I put the
stupid thing.
Okay, cool. So now I can actually
but
Now we'll do video format X.
Video resolution
timeline.
Add the courses in here.
Streaming high quality content, my guy.
There's no high quality content here.
I'm exhausted.
Yeah, but you can't just set the bar low
and then be like, "Oh, yeah, it's
great."
zero.
Oh, did I get the aspect ratio wrong?
the fade thing. Add fade.
Oops.
It's in like increments of
what is it points or what's it called?
encoding overload.
No idea what's wrong with stream.
Well, something's wrong with stream. I
don't know what.
for the puffer?
I know I should.
Oh yeah. Did you see me making this
thing convert? This trailer is made in
sea.
My video editor wasn't available, so I
said fine. I'll program the shader. I
mean, I'll program the trailer.
Oh, handling the barn. I see.
I figure you might like this thing. This
is my phone that I got. A minimal one.
It's great. It doesn't do anything. I
never touch it.
I still like
I still end up scrolling X on my
desktop, but not on my phone ever.
Minimal.
It's got an e- in display like a Kindle
on it. It's too bright. I actually I
wish it weren't as bright, but um I
basically only use my phone now for
audiobooks and text. It's great.
There a lot of Amish around here.
They're pretty good at barns. Like
actually really good at barns.
Yeah, mine is steel.
This is more than just a barn.
I mean, the amount of time I spend in
here,
I'd hope so. I like this place.
This is for more than storing horses.
It's restoring Hey,
These things have got to not [ __ ]
flash constantly.
I mean, Muffin, my editor was out. I
figured it would be quicker for me to
just like do it.
I think I did a decent job, didn't I,
Weston?
It'll be snappy. I got to voice it
still.
Maybe the puffer goes a little earlier,
you know, like
just like that.
Maybe here.
Well, you want to see the start of the
the nova animation though, right?
You don't want it to cover the start of
the nova animation.
I think I even overdid it a little bit.
I think it should be
Maybe like this.
right, let's render this thing
and then I'm going to send this to
Spencer. I'm going to be like, "Hey, I
got to voice this, but whatever.
tips for learning CUDA? How to do FFT
from scratch for a project? Well, CUDA
literally has an FFT library. So, you
can use that as a reference and CUDA is
just C that runs on your GPU.
So, you write C and it runs on your GPU.
And you can paralyze it really stupid
like just doing like FFT on a bunch of
sequences. Um, you can paralyze it kind
of smart like, but it's just C that runs
on your GPU. That's the dumb idiot
version that actually is kind of
correct.
I used the wrong [ __ ] clip. Hang on,
guys.
I usually like to do things and learn as
I go
how a GPU works. So a GPU,
it's like a CPU with 20,000 cores that's
optimized for SIMD.
So it likes to do the same instruction
on a bunch of different data.
And it has it's like it's like a domain
specific language that's just built to
do multipprocessing on a ton of cores
where branching is bad,
but it's basically like C, which is
cool.
what FFT?
Oh, yeah. You can't use it as a
reference. Ha. Well, you can use it as a
reference for performance. You can't
look at the code.
If you want to do some cool CUDA, you
can write puffer lib environments.
Actually, those are just C. Uh, you can
help us make our kernels fast.
Fair bit of cuda experience. Maybe then
don't think I'll be helpful right now.
You'd be surprised, I tell you.
Wait, what the [ __ ]
No, it isn't. We're good.
We'll let the whole thing run. It'll
render and then I'll be good.
There was a fade out before, wasn't
there?
Oh, there was no fade out.
What the [ __ ] man?
Undo.
Dude,
[ __ ] man.
What the hell?
Piece of [ __ ]
Yeah,
I think it's better without the fade.
Can I say
probably tighten the script a little
bit?
If I just read this, how long does it
take?
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib 4. Our latest
release learns new policies in seconds
with a pure CUDA training back end and a
new hardware efficient architecture that
combines Mingru and highway connection.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPs and analyze them in con
installation. New dashboard that runs
locally browser 20 plus optimized
environments and only 5,000 lines of
training code. Puffer li is an open
source toolkit for RL.
The open is it puffer. Get started
today. Okay. So, it's actually it's not
that it's too much text. It's too much
text at the start.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with upper lib 4. Our pure CUDA
training back end learns policies in
seconds. A hardware efficient
architecture.
Okay, so that's the problem is that I
only have the first literally eight
seconds to say the first two lines.
So, we have to actually like crunch this
a lot.
That's going to be the thing.
The startup podcast will roast you for
that.
Good. Then they'll cover it.
train agents at 20 million steps per
second with buffer lips pure CUDA
training back
I'm I'm
They know about Puffer, but they do
LLMs.
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer Lib's new CUDA
training back end.
Michael Reeves.
Was that
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer's pure CUDA back end.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines Minrew and highway networks.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with Constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser.
With 20 plus optimized environments and
only 5,000 lines of training code,
Puffer Lib is the open source toolkit
for RL. Visit puffer.ai to puff up your
reinforcement learning.
Prime does tooling. Oh, wait. Prime. You
meant Primagen, not I thought you meant
Prime. Prime intellect. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. He's fun. I actually learned
um there's some engineering stuff I
learned from him when I was getting into
lowlevel.
Well, more so he was the guy that got me
thinking way more about um procedural
programming,
which then led me to uh a lot of the
low-level stuff I
Select gang. They do LLM stuff, right?
Like
they don't do the same RL.
It's very different.
Head hunting drone swarms.
The robot that tasers you. Oh, wait.
I'm trying. I might know him. That's
cool.
Yeah, I'm happy to talk to like those
types of people if any of them are
interested. For sure.
Well, hey, um, go link him, right? Like,
go link him and say he's got like a big
release coming up next week, um, or
whatever. I mean, that's how a lot of
this stuff happens, right? like viewers,
if you want to help me out for free and
really help push the project forward,
just like go tell people like that about
it and then maybe you'll get a podcast
episode out of it and maybe Puffer will
get a lot of stars and I'll have more
time for dev. That'd be great.
Like the less time I have to spend
advertising and the more I just we sign
fewer higher value contracts instead of
a ton of lower value contracts, the more
time I have for the open source dev.
What do you guys think? Anything else I
should do tonight or should I
sign off of this and just try to voice
this thing?
It'll probably take me a bunch of takes.
buffer to the curriculum. Yeah, that's
cool.
Yeah, I mean like you can just tell
people, oh yeah, you know, I like I
dropped by the stream. I can probably
get him to like um you know to give a
little tutorial or something like that
with the new release
cuz once this thing is released, I'll be
very happy to do a bunch of tutorials
and stuff. You guys just are going to
have to give me a few days to actually
just do nothing so that I get some brain
cells back and I get a lot less grumpy.
But then absolutely
5,000 lines of it's 5,000 lines of
training code.
It's cudacy.
I say it's a cuda back end up here. It's
like a thousand additional lines of
Python glue. Really nothing.
Code is insane.
Great compression. Yeah,
the thing I guess technically you could
say well it still uses torch but it
actually only uses torch for sweeps like
this. And when I say for sweeps I mean
to suggest the next set of
hyperparameters
because I didn't feel like porting a
Gaussian process to uh to CUDA.
Very easily could though.
I think at some point the whole thing
will just be CUDA, but it is completely
true that the whole training back end at
the moment is CUDA.
Yeah, fair.
Puffer jwars at puffer.ai. It's on the
website. Replace the puffer fish with
dots.
Um, this pricing is officially outdated
as a 40,
but we do not charge universities and uh
university labs or anything. That's all
free opens for stuff.
horses and all that. It's all free.
on one of your replies.
Oh, Jess. Um,
I think it's more so
if people are like, "Oh, you know, like
I'm looking for cool projects or
whatever." Check out, you know, check
out puffer live by Jacewarriors or
whatever. Hyperf reinforcement learning
like uh new backends in CUDA like is
pure CUDA whatever that type thing. 20
MSPS training solves whatever in seconds
that just whatever you know whatever you
feel
you all want to do grassroots you do
grassroots.
It is up to you. It does help though.
Should I try to just voice this trailer
live on stream?
There's technically no reason I can't.
I have Audacity in here.
Audacity.
It's literally just Audacity.
Uh, I do not want to be on whatever the
[ __ ] that is, man. Eric,
I don't even really want to be on any of
the big ones to be honest with you. Like
the big ones that are super bullshitty.
I mean, technically, yeah, it's good
exposure, but I'd be way happier just
talking to the actual technical people
that care about engineering and science.
writing environments in CUDA makes
sense.
It's kind of weird. So, there's a small
amount of overhead that you can
eliminate for the really simple M's in
CUDA.
Um I think yeah seen like just ported
breakout to CUDA and it takes like five
minutes. You barely have to change any
code. Um so you can do that. uh for
environments that have heavy physics, it
makes sense, but then for the
environments in between, like the
environments that have a bunch of
branching logic,
uh I think it's generally going to just
make it harder to debug and actually be
slower because GPUs are not good at
branching logic and you're spending your
GPU cycles when you could be overlapping
the compute with the CPU instead.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's using my wrong mic.
Audio set up
top of the toolbar.
See, I see the scarlet here. Right.
Analog input scarlet.
See that doesn't pick anything up.
RL is more CPUbound.
Well, it is if you write shitty CPU
code. If you're writing stuff in static
memory optimize C, it's not. And then
you're actually correctly doing host
device transfers.
But yeah, like everything outside of
Puffer is mega CPUbound. I spent two
years fixing that [ __ ] Man,
wasn't easy.
only use gym because I do for uni
world mods where I saw some GPU usage.
Allow me to show you my friend.
That was with a 32,000 parameter model.
Tiny
even something like this
300 watts
full utilization,
it's only 400k per.
And then if I do something that's like 6
mil per, it's full full utilization of
the card.
never beat Breakout. So, the thing is
that dreamer line of work is borderline
scientific fraud. Um, we literally have
a nerup paper showing that it at least
doesn't work for the reasons that they
say it does.
None of the tricks work for the reasons
they say they work. None of them
generalize outside of Dreamer, even
though they present them as perfectly
general. And myself and several others
have tried to do stuff with that thing,
and it just doesn't [ __ ] work.
So
there you go.
Cam link audio
So I mean I see the analog input here
for the Scarlet, but it doesn't have a
bar.
But it shows up, which is weird.
Um, pulse.
It's still pretty cool. It really isn't
because it's like one of those like
clever sounding ideas that just doesn't
work.
They also kind of glaze over the fact
that they just make the model 10x bigger
from uh two to three.
It honestly took a lot of um a lot of
focus off of the stuff that actually
does work.
Okay.
Does this do anything?
test.
Still on the wrong device.
Well, I'm going to have to try to switch
the input in the settings. And if it
breaks my audio, it breaks my audio.
Test.
Okay. Well, it hasn't broken my audio
here.
And now it doesn't launch. Cool.
So, uh, having that microphone on makes
it not launch. That's very cool.
We put this back.
And what if I just use OBS for the audio
recording? As dumb as that is, it's got
a compressor on it and everything.
Does this audio sound, if I get up to
here, does the audio sound reasonable
for uh recording?
That would be the really dumb way of
doing it, right?
Train agents at 20 million steps per
second with Puffer's pure CUDA back end.
Our hardware efficient architecture
combines mining and highway connections.
Automate thousands of experiments with
multiGPU sweeps and analyze them
instantly with Constellation, our new
dashboard that runs locally and in your
browser. With 20 plus optimized
environments and only 5,000 lines of
training code, Puffer Lib is the
open-source toolkit for RL. Visit
puffer.ai AI to puff up your re